[Musique]
c'est dans la grèce antique
berceau de la civilisation occidentale
que naît le stoïcisme au 3e siècle avant
notre ère héritier de la philosophie de
platon et des cyniques le stoïcisme
n'est pas seulement une doctrine c'est
un art de vivre
car pour les stoïciens comprendre le
monde n'est que la première étape vers
le but véritable de notre existence être
heureux dans cette vidéo vous allez
découvrir 10 citation qui résume la
philosophie des stoïciens 10 citations
qui renferme les clés d'une vie sage et
heureuse
en espérant qu'elle éveille en vous
l'envi de découvrir cette fameuse école
de pensée
[Musique]
à
non
n'attends pas que les événements
arrivent comme tu le souhaites décide de
vouloir ce qui arrive est tu seras la
philosophie stoïcienne est fondé sur une
idée simple le monde est rationnel dire
que le monde est rationnel c'est dire
que tous les événements qui se
produisent sont le résultat d'un
enchaînement de causes et d'effets
autrement dit que tout ce qui arrive
doit arriver
la plupart du temps nous réagissons de
manière émotionnelle face aux événements
nous nous réjouissons quand les faits
nous sont favorables et nous nous
plaignons quand ceux qui arrivent
contrarient nos désirs ou nos attentes
mais nous ne voyons pas quand nous
comportant ainsi nous nous condamnons à
la déception nous nous condamnons à une
vie de souffrance en désirant que les
événements nous soit favorable
nous nous rendons esclaves des
événements nous faisons dépendre notre
bonheur de ceux qui précisément ne
dépend pas de nous les stoïciens nous
invite à adopter une attitude
rationnelle face aux événements
comprendre que tout ce qui arrive à une
raison d'arrivée et l'accepter faire
alors
j'accède à la paix intérieure je goûte à
la joie de l'harmonie avec le monde dès
l'aurore dit toi tu avances je vais
rencontrer un indiscret un ingrat un
insolent un fourbe un envieux un égoïste
pour les stoïciens la cause de notre
souffrance se situe dans nos attentes
vis-à-vis du monde extérieur
ainsi nous faisons dépendre notre
bonheur de facteurs qui pour l'immense
majorité ne dépendent pas de nous la
conséquence de cette attente c'est que
lorsque les événements n'obéissent pas
au scénario idéal que nous espérions
nous souffrons or les stoïciens nous
rappelle que le monde est ainsi fait
décevant et un parfait et que vouloir
que le monde soit sans défaut c'est
vouloir que le monde ne soit pas le
monde ce qui est insensé
de même la nature humaine est criblé
d'imperfections l'égoïsme l'orgueil la
méchanceté l'hypocrisie et nous devons
faire avec
nous devons l'accepter car vouloir que
la nature humaine ne soit plus la nature
humaine
c'est vouloir quelque chose d'impossible
en nous préparant mentalement à côtoyer
les défauts du genre humain
nous nous déchargeons des émotions
négatives liées à l'inrs acceptation de
ce qui ne peut être changé la raison
veut décider ce qui est juste la colère
veut qu'on trouve juste ce qu'elle a
décidé l'âme humaine est le théâtre
d'une lutte entre deux forces
la raison et les émotions les émotions
que les stoïciens hommes les passions
trouble notre jugement
elles nous font prendre les choses
personnellement nous rendent au style ou
complaisants nous porte à l'exagération
ou à l'atténuation bien souvent nous
croyons juger les choses de manière
rationnelle
alors que c'est une émotion qui guide
notre raisonnement
nous sommes persuadés d'être dans le
juste parce que nous ne faisons qu'un
avec l'émotion qui nous anime
il en va ainsi de la colère qui nous
fait perdre tout recul sur les choses et
qui cherche à s'imposer au détriment de
la raison
lorsque nous sommes en colère nous
refusons toute nuance toute concession
envers l'objet de notre colère
les émotions nous empêche de voir la
réalité telle qu'elle est et ce faisant
elle nous conduisent à prendre de
mauvaises décisions
les décisions qui se retourneront
ensuite contre nous alimentant ainsi le
cycle de la colère et du sentiment
d'injustice pour les stoïciens la colère
est l'une des émotions les plus néfastes
car en plus de nous détourner de la voie
du juste
elle fait de nous la première victime de
ces effets
[Musique]
ce qui trouble les hommes ce ne sont pas
les choses mais les jugement qu'il porte
sur les choses lorsque nous souffrons
nous attribuons spontanément l'origine
de notre souffrance à une cause
extérieure à nous si je suis en colère
c'est parce qu'on m'a mis en colère si
je suis déçu découragé ou déprimés c'est
parce que telle personne m'a trahi parce
que les gens sont méchants ou parce que
l'univers est contre moi
les stoïciens répondent à cela que ce ne
sont pas les choses qui nous affecte
mais la manière dont nous réagissons aux
choses
ce n'est pas la trahison de mon ami qui
me fait souffrir c'est la colère que
j'éprouve envers lui or je suis seul
responsable de ma colère nous ne sommes
pas responsables de ce que font les
autres
par contre nous sommes entièrement
responsable de la manière dont nous
réagissons à ce que font les autres
seul ce qui dépend de nous et de notre
responsabilité et rien de ce dont nous
ne sommes pas responsables ne saurait
nous être imputé rien de ce dont nous ne
sommes pas responsables ne saurait nous
affecter cette citation est à mettre en
parallèle avec la phrase de marc aurèle
qui disaient considérer les occasions
votre chagrin et votre colère vous ont
causé plus de souffrance que les faits
eux-mêmes en apprenant à séparer les
choses du jugement que nous portons sur
elle
nous nous libérons du trouble lié à ce
qui ne dépend pas de nous
l'émeraude ne perd pas de sa valeur
faute de louanges
nous sommes tous animés par un désir de
reconnaissance lorsque nous faisons
quelque chose de bien
dutil ou d'admirables nous aimons
recevoir des compliments qui viendront
confirmer la valeur de nos actes et par
prolongement notre estime de nous mêmes
al'inverse rien ne nous est plus
insupportable que l'ingratitude
l'inattention à nos efforts et l'absence
de remerciement
ce désir de reconnaissance traduit notre
besoin de nous sentir important aux yeux
des autres mais en nous comportant ainsi
nous faisons dépendre notre valeur du
jugement d'autrui
c'est à dire de quelque chose qui ne
dépend pas de notre volonté ni même de
nos actes
il ne dépend pas de nous que les
personnes que nous côtoyons soient
sensibles à nos qualités
attentive à nos efforts ou consciente de
notre valeur et vouloir le leur
reprocher c'est considérer que leur
jugement a plus d'importance que la
réalité
l'émeraude ne perd pas de sa valeur
faute de louanges comme nous ne perdons
pas de notre valeur faute de compliments
l'accepter c'est se libérer du besoin de
reconnaissance qui nous rend dépendant
du jugement des autres
[Musique]
quand tu auras désappris à espérer je
t'apprendrai à vouloir espérer c'est
désirer ce qui ne dépend pas de nous
vouloir c'est désirer ce qui dépend de
nous l'espoir est souvent perçu comme un
sentiment positif comme un moyen de
supporter les difficultés
en attendant des lendemains meilleurs
l'espoir fait vivre dit le proverbe
or les stoïciens nous font remarquer qu
espéré c'est compter sur la survenue
d'un événement qu'il ne dépend pas de
nous de faire advenir espérer c'est se
placer dans la situation de dépendre de
facteurs qui nous sont étrangers au lieu
d'agir sur ce qui dépend de nous de
modifier ou de provoquer l'espoir est
une projection de l'esprit au contraire
la volonté est une force d'action
espérait s'est jouée à la loterie avec
la réalité et c'est être déçu quand la
réalité ne sort pas les numéros sur
lesquels nous avions misé vouloir c'est
se donner les moyens de créer les
numéros que nous souhaitons voir sortir
pour les stoïciens nous devons remplacer
l'espoir par la volonté la volonté étant
fondée sur la conscience de notre
pouvoir d' influence et non sur les
caprices du hasard nous avons la
capacité de faire advenir certaines
choses et pas d'autres nous avons la
capacité d'influencer le monde
dans la limite de notre rayon d'action
seul importe ce qui dépend de nous et ce
qui dépend de nous doit être soutenue
non par nos espoirs mais par notre
volonté tout ce qui est possible à
l'homme ne peut être au dessus de tes
forces le stoïcisme est une philosophie
de la lucidité être lucide c'est voir la
réalité de manière rationnelle
sans y projeter ni la lumière de nos
espoirs ni l'ombre de nos appréhensions
or notre conception de ce qui est
possible et de ce qui ne l'est pas porte
souvent l'empreinte de notre pessimisme
nous baissons les bras avant même
d'avoir commencé
nous nous avons vaincu sans même nous
être donné une chance de réussir
pourtant nous connaissons tous des
personnes qui ont su surmonter les
obstacles pour réaliser ce qui à
première vue sembler impossible
ces personnes sont la preuve qu'il
existe un écart entre ce qui nous semble
possible et ce qui est possible
cette citation de marc aurèle est un
appel à la conscience de notre pouvoir
d'action de la même façon qu'il est
illusoire de vouloir changer ce qui ne
dépend pas de nous il est tout aussi
insensé de ne pas voir les choses qui
dépendent de nous et que la seule chose
qui nous sépare d'elle c'est notre
volonté d'agir
loin d'être une philosophie de la
passivité face aux événements le
stoïcisme est une philosophie de
l'action consciente agir en sachant
distinguer ce qui ne dépend pas de nous
est ce que nous avons le pouvoir de
changer que la force me soit donné de
supporter ce qui ne peut être changer le
courage de changer ce qui peut l'être et
la sagesse de distinguer l'un de l'autre
que doit-on accepter ce qui ne dépend
pas de nous car refuser ce qu'il n'est
pas en notre pouvoir de changer c'est se
condamner à une vie de malheur que
peut-on changer ce qui dépend de nous ce
sur quoi nous avons un pouvoir
d'influencé par nos actions par nos
paroles ou nos décisions ces principes
possède une telle évidence logique que
les formules et s'apparente à une
offense contre l'intelligence et
pourtant nous repoussons ses principes
comme si leur simplicité ne parvenait
pas à satisfaire notre besoin de
compliquer les choses comme si le fait
d'intellectualiser des choses simples
nous procurer un sentiment de sagesse
pour les stoïciens la véritable
intelligence ne se situe pas dans le
fait de rejeter des principes évident
mais dans notre pouvoir de discerner là
où il s'applique et là où il ne
s'applique pas la véritable intelligence
et d'ordre pratique
elle concerne notre rapport à la réalité
concrète de l'existence être sage c'est
faire primer la lucidité et la raison
sur nos choix et nos actions
l'important n'est pas ce qu'on a fait de
nous mais ce qu'on fait de ce qu'on a
fait de nous cette citation n'a pas pour
auteur un philosophe stoïcien
mais un philosophe contemporain jean
paul sartre sartre est le fondateur du
courant existentialiste une école de
pensée qui affirme que l'homme est
absolument libre et qu' il n'est soumis
à aucune autre contrainte que celle
qu'il se donne à lui même pour sartre
l'existence humaine est une succession
de choix et chaque nouvelle seconde de
notre vie nous met face à une infinité
de choix possible quel rapport avec le
stoïcisme et bien comme les stoïciens
sartre nous montre que l'homme est
maître de son destin
il n'a certes pas le pouvoir de changer
ce que la vie a fait de lui mais il a le
pouvoir d'agir sur ce qui dépend de lui
ici et maintenant vous n'êtes pas libre
de modifier votre passé mais vous êtes
libre d'agir au présent pour façonner
votre avenir
le stoïcisme est une philosophie qui
rend à l'homme son pouvoir de maîtrise
ce pouvoir de maîtrise n'est pas un
pouvoir de toute puissance
il ne s'étend pas au delà des limites de
notre sphère d'influencé
il y à ce qui dépend de nous il y a ceux
qui ne dépend pas de nous mais à trop
nous focaliser sur ce qui ne dépend pas
de nous nous en oublions tout ce qu'il
nous est possible de changer en nous et
autour de nous nous en oublions que
personne d'autre que nous mêmes ne sera
l'auteur de notre prochaine action et
qui ne tient qu'à nous de transformer le
possible en réalité
non
cette vidéo est maintenant terminée
j'espère qu'elle vous aura donné envie
d'explorer plus en profondeur cette
philosophie éminemment actuelle qu'est
le stoïcisme on se retrouve bientôt pour
un nouvel épisode
et d'ici là n'oubliez pas que la
philosophie n'a d'intérêt que si elle
nourrit votre âme effet s'élever votre
conscience je vous remercie
[Musique]